welcome everybody to this 45-minute
webinar on jean-paul sartre on human
freedom and responsibility this is one
I've been looking forward to for quite
some time and I see that we've got quite
a few people joining us which is great I
think that we'll probably have more as
the hour goes on so I think most of you
probably know me but I'll introduce
myself anyway in case anybody doesn't
I'm Greg Sadler I'm the president of
reason i/o and offering these these
sorts of webinars and online seminars is
one of our our big activities with
reason al our company I'm an online
educator I'm an advocate of virtue
ethics Sartre is kind of at odds with
them but he also fits in in interesting
ways perhaps supplements it
my interest in Sartre goes back all the
way to my undergraduate days at Lakeland
College now Lakeland University where I
went through what we can call a Sartre
phase there's actually a video out there
that that talks a bit about that and
that went on all the way into my
graduate days and at a certain point I
ended up leaving start behind the came
back to him and there's a lot that I
find very interesting about his works so
what I'd like to do in this webinar is
do a very brief introductory discussion
and then we'll discuss three main topics
each with its own subtopics and we're
not going to go all that deep in into
these in this 45-minute webinar in part
because I have 20 minutes reserved for
QA and discussion and I'm going to try
my best to stay on time with with all of
this sometimes we go over a little bit
but but I don't want to go too deep into
it and answer it is a quite systematic
thinker so there's always going to be a
lot more than will we'll get to so let's
talk about a couple key questions that
come up inevitably
I think for most human beings at one
point or another in their life and and
we can talk about asking these in a
general way and we can talk about asking
these in a much more personal
existentially oriented way so one key
question is are we human beings
genuinely free we have all sorts of
experiences that seem to indicate to us
a kind of unfreedom in in our own lives
so that's that's a good question and
then you know a lot of people may be
troubled by what neuroscience has to say
or by what other sorts of you know new
Sciences or fields may may have to weigh
in about about whether we genuinely are
free and then we have to ask this
question what is freedom in its essence
I think freedom is one of those
ambiguous terms where when people get
into debates about this they often
aren't actually meaning the same thing
by that that term another key issue
especially for Sartre is does freedom
bear upon itself is it something that is
reflexive is it something that could be
expanded or contracted and then you know
another question that that inevitably
comes up from from adolescents often and
can we do anything we like with our
freedom there is a tendency to think of
freedom as sort of value neutral and
totally unrestricted perhaps there's an
internal logic to to freedom itself
start certainly seem to think that there
was something like that that introduced
a kind of normativity to it so two key
texts for these topics you know not just
in in Sark's work but in in general I
would say that we're going to make some
reference to is his existentialism is a
humanism great little essay where he is
trying to explain existentialism for a
popular audience I often assign it to my
ethics students as our reading on Sartre
and then his big thick massive early
book being
and nothing is liquid and they aren't
really wonderful book very dense it does
require I think some background in
reading some other philosophers who
Sartre is playing off of but it's its
flavor world topic number one that I
wanted to talk about is what we can call
sart's anthropology and you notice that
we've got four subtopics that we're
going to explore in that so I've got one
slide for each of these some some
working notes and keep in mind we'll
have plenty of time for Q&A at the end
so if anything catches your eye or
anything you feel goes over your head at
this point you say I don't know what the
hell he's talking about there just bring
it up and we'll go back to it and go
over it so when we talk about
philosophical anthropology that's not a
term that's used that much anymore but
it's it's something worth reminding
ourselves about anthropology begins as
the study of human beings and what we
nowadays know as anthropology has
spiraled off into a number of different
disciplines and and theoretical
perspectives some of which you know
combine well with each other some of
which don't but the its ultimate origin
was you know looking at human beings and
trying to come up with a ology a logos
for what it is that we've been so far
and you know as the existentialist
pointed out like Heidegger and Sartre
this is human being trying to examine
what human being is so it's an
inherently reflexive activity and
traditionally it was focused on
determining what human nature is or if
we another way of placing or putting it
is you know asking the question what is
the essence of the human being
and you know it's easy to come up with
nice definitions you know taking them
just out of Aristotle or Hui theist or
the Stoics you know the human being is
the rational animal
we can ask ourselves great what does
that mean what does that entail you know
and philosophical anthropology is really
sort of a crossroads where we see
metaphysics ethics social and political
philosophy and psychology
all coming together so search because a
soft apology of a sort running
throughout his works but it's going to
be kind of a strange one in that he is
going to be denying that there is a
essence a you know pre-given essence or
nature to human being so let's let's
talk about that Sarge has this famous
phrase that existence precedes essence
and he says that that is the hallmark of
existentialist philosophy now of course
he was really good this is a bit of a
side note at sort of dominating the the
field of of what would come to be called
existentialism and he kind of pushed the
others who are using that term out of it
once they realized what Sartre was
meaning by the term you see Gabriel
Marcel or Martin Heidegger saying you
can keep it we don't want it anymore
we'll call what we're doing something
different but that that said what Sartre
is articulating is is really quite
interesting he's he's rejecting some
some views on human nature that had been
around for quite a while and in in
existentialism is a humanism he
explicitly rejects two main views and
and I suppose you could read the
Enlightenment views back into ancient
conceptions of human nature although I
don't know that that's exactly a great
fit but so he talks about ways in which
people have traditionally understood
human nature that we were something sort
of like to use his example a penknife
something that is a created being
something that has a given essence and
you know Christians of course they had
kind of an easy way of understanding
this god created everything so God
created not only individual human beings
but created individual human beings as
human beings so with a common nature and
include enlightenment didn't really get
rid of this this idea they got rid of
God but then they would appeal to other
more secularized viewpoints on this and
it's really you know as far as Sartain
is concerned the same thing he argues
instead that there is no human nature or
essence and this so this raises a really
interesting question should as if we're
reading this and taking it very
seriously some perplexity or some some
anxiousness he does say that there is
one being for whom existence precedes
essence and we have to ask ourselves
what what does this mean and there's two
things that we should keep in mind one
is that he's not saying that there are
no essences to things as a matter of
fact most things do have essences and
they have pre-given essences human being
is the one kind of being for whom he
says existence precedes essence the
other thing is we have to ask ourselves
you know what what does existence mean
in this case the existence of what and
Sartre goes on to affirm that although
there isn't a human nature essence there
is nevertheless a universal human
condition and I you know this isn't the
totality of what he says about that but
I picked out two traits that I think are
really key to that being as he calls it
in situation and having to choose these
are things that apply to his motion
freedom I'm another thing to keep in
mind and again we're not going to go
very deep into the metaphysics involved
here but I did want to bring this up
starts early work does this key work is
being and nothingness and he's taking
from Heidegger some very interesting
starting points about what Heidegger
calls the nothing das nicht and.and he's
talking about it
in terms of nothingness any sense that
if not something that is merely
reducible to a set of negations or
negative judgments that far he's
following Heidegger so there is a
nothingness and we can't even say that
it is if we get at a very paradoxical
thinking and language here but Sartre
says that the human beings experience
and and at the pose and fear realities
that have negation in their inner
structure they're not just the human
being you know seeing something that's a
positivity and then negating it through
say an intellectual act but rather we
apprehend things in their non being in
their lack in how they you know they
they show to us what they are not as
just as much as what they are and he's
got lots of examples that we can talk
about one of the other things that he
says that that is very interesting he
thinks is looked too far to the side of
giving nothingness its own kind of
domain and he says human being is the
being by which nothingness comes to
things we are the ones that are actually
in true that that are that are allowing
nothingness to be and to have all of
these negative attitudes just as part of
what we are this is another important
distinction as well the in it's often
the for itself and this connects up with
this discussion of the nothing so cert
uses this essentially Hegelian language
in a somewhat different way than Hegel
does he talks about being in itself and
this is the being of objects of the
world that's it's what he calls a
plenitude of being there is no
negativity in it by it by its own nature
being for itself is the kind of beings
that we are the beings of consciousness
and he's got this great formula it is
not what it is or it is what it is not
that's part of the way that it that it
is or exists
he also tells us that freedom is is
really at the core of things I almost
said essential there and actually if we
wanted to use essential I think we could
we could say that that probably is
something that is essential in the
classic sense but if the kind of
essentiality that undoes there being a
fixed essence ahead of time freedom is
something that he says is part of our
ontological condition and this comes
ultimately at least in his system from
this this fact that we can take up
negative stances towards the in itself
towards the whole world of other beings
he talks about us as as deploying the
nothing from ourselves as as introducing
it there and not just as a sort of
judgment but as as helping to produce
the negativities that that we encounter
he also talks about the for itself as
being and this is a term he uses a lot a
transcendence of the in itself the very
fact that we can have this conversation
right now means that we're already
transcending to a certain extent the
world of the the in itself the in itself
can't talk about itself it can't take a
position on itself it can't be other
than it is and so he'll talk about the
human being as being both what he calls
facticity which we'll talk about in a
bit and transcendence so this is this is
a good lead-in to the the next sort of
topics that i want to talk about who's
going to get us closer to freedom and
its relationship with determinism one of
the key things that Sartre is concerned
to do is to show that that although
there is determination and there is a
kind of determinism for the in itself
there can't be anything like that that
would completely condition the for
itself and that's that's part of what it
means for the for itself to be free and
this depends on
the negativity that is involved so if we
talk about human nature if we did have
human nature then the possibilities for
a human being would in fact be
restricted to a certain extent by that
human nature or essence it could be a
very wide range of possibilities you
think about you know Aristotle or the
Stoics or Thomas Aquinas or whoever you
liked it Rene Descartes talking about
there being a human nature and using
their Hermann what this is already a
reflexive act right there there's you
know a wide range of possibilities for
somebody like Aristotle or Rene
Descartes or a manual cut but ultimately
you would reach a kind of limit in the
way that Sartre sees it and there would
also be and of teleology involved that
would give us an idea about what being
in a better or finished state would be
for cert if existence precedes essence
then what is what does this mean for us
this means that we don't have any sort
of narrative that would be set out in
advance by which we could measure our
development or decline for human beings
we can't for example say you know the
way the Stoics do that every being wants
to do what it needs to do in order to
develop its own being and to maintain
itself in existence and then with human
beings as we as we do this and we
develop further we discover that we have
a rational and social nature and it
requires us to go against some of our
initial you know self-centeredness force
art that's a possibility but it's only
one of many it's not the possibility
that makes sense of all of the other
ones as sort of the paradigm the other
thing to keep in mind for Sartre is when
he talks about potentiality he views
that as a lack or an
activity that's not there in the thing
as such as sort of you know a property
that it would have totally independent
of any human consciousness its human
consciousness that realizes the
possibilities of things and often not
all of the possibilities at once we're
going to talk about this when we get to
history so force art the very notion of
this human act as intentional is going
to transcend whatever determinism one
might one might begin to imagine this is
something that he talks about in the
section of Being and Nothingness that he
calls being and doing freedom joining
talks about the freedom as being the
first condition of action so here's a
good place to talk a bit about facticity
this this funny word that he's coined so
going back to this notion of the for
itself the for itself that is what we
are it does exist as presents to the
world we're not a pure consciousness all
by ourselves before we then connect up
with the world the way if you remember
how de Kurt walked us through his
meditations you know you have this Koji
toe which was was you know totally
independent of the world of extension
which might not even exist until we
prove that God exists and and you know
how all of that goes for certain oh we
are stuck in the world and and that's
part of what our condition is we're not
just our negativity we're not just our
capacity to transcend we were not just
being what we're not we are also what we
are and so he talks about there's a
beautiful phrase a perpetual contingency
of the in itself that haunts the for
itself and he says this is what our
facticity is so those are some some
pretty fancy words what is what does
contingency contingency is the fact that
everything could be different then than
it is there is no inherent or internal
necessity to my being Who I am or having
had the
stry that I do or talking to you here in
Milwaukee as opposed to in New York or
in Timbuktu all of that is it all of
that is and is the case but all of that
is ultimately contingent and this is
what he says what allows the for itself
to be and to exist it's sort of our
anchoring point in the world now how do
we grasp our facticity we grasp it
through being being for itself so we
grasp it as something that is of us but
we say that's not totally what I am or
we might actually say this is totally
what I am that's one of the
possibilities for us so let's talk about
a couple ways in which determinism can
can arise and we're not going to get
very deep into this again Sartre
discusses what he calls biological
determinism which would be based on
capacities and constitution what he
means here a great example of this that
he gives in existentialism is a humanism
there's people who say that I'm cowardly
by Nature right I can't stand up for
myself because that's just the way I am
Sartre would see you know Sartre so it
has no problem saying yeah we can have
all sorts of drives we can have all
sorts of things that that conditioned us
I may be as a person more subject to
irritability and a Raska bility just by
the way I'm put together than some other
people are other people maybe you know
of a different temperament but that
doesn't determine us we we can transcend
that it doesn't mean that we can totally
leave it behind he also talked about
psychological determinism here we would
talk about you know having a set of
responses because of our experiences and
associations we've developed so you know
for example if somebody says well you
know I have to be a racist because
that's just the way I was brought up
Sartre would say well that's a really
interesting excuse but it doesn't really
hold and and you know this is actually
going to be a place I should mention
where somebody like Simone de Beauvoir
will point out certain situations and
say maybe a person could have a much
lesser degree of freedom so he thinks
that it's up to us what we make of our
person the situation that we're in the
capacities that we find ourselves with
we are always able to choose something
we also exist in historical situations
and here you've got this wonderful
discussion of this again in that being
and doing freedom section towards the
end of being and nothing else and it
talks about us apprehending historical
situations in their plenitude of being
that is we're confronted with them as
how things are and we don't realize the
possibilities in them that are non
beings he gives the example of four you
know workers who don't realize how
exploited they are because they they
don't have the the you might say
apparatus yet to make sense of it so
when they revolt they don't know what to
do with their revolt afterwards one of
the really interesting things that he
says in this section is that discussions
of free will and determinism are to use
his term tedious because they're
artificial and abstract and actually I
do find this to be the case for much of
the literature out there on free will
and determinism as well as much as what
goes on the blogosphere and video sphere
and all of that search focus is on the
the structure of intentional action and
he talks about the cause or motive which
we look at as being you know
determinative a determinist looks just
at the cause or motive the act which is
where we intervene in the present and
then the end which is which is not yet
realized and he says that all three of
these are connected up with with each
other and that they cannot be you know
an intentional action completely reduced
to one or the other so the act is not
simply reducible to the cause or the
motive although the cause or motive is
there otherwise it would not be an
intentional act so the way that he talks
about it
if we follow what he's saying I'm
involved as both free and within a
matrix of non-existence in being those
are possibilities that I can open up and
realize but I am in being so it's not as
if I can you know suddenly just dispense
with everything that's out there our
freedom is indeed conditioned by our
historical situations so now we come to
talking about human responsibility and
we're a little bit past time but I hope
that you you stick with me on this so
we're going to talk about several
different topics one is is whether we
can appeal to some kind of transcendent
values in order to ground or justify or
determine our choices and Sartre says no
we cannot and he frames us in terms of
you know the the Dostoevsky and passage
if God does not exist then is everything
permitted or is everything possible
Sartre notes and there may be some good
debate about this that there are there
aren't any transcendent values that can
compel our choice that tell us we
automatically have to do X or Y the
transcendence that they do possess stems
from our own choice to recognize them so
we are always at bottom responsible and
this places us in a situation of what he
calls anguish Heidegger and Kierkegaard
you know it's oxd as a matter of fact I
think that that's wrong for Kierkegaard
it's a different Danish word but it's
what they translated in German is ankh
and and we translate it as anxiety or
anguish Sartre stresses that this is
different than fear fears of the in
itself or the other beings or or of you
know other people anguish is anguish
before oneself and so part of this stems
from having to choose and not having a
way to decide that does not ultimately
depend upon us this means that we're
responsible and so the anguish is an
effective response that stems from the
realization of our freedom it doesn't
always feel good to be free that's a
matter of fact this is
why people try to avoid it in what's our
calls bad fate here he has a very
interesting analysis he talks about bad
faith as as different than lying to the
other person because you have to lie to
yourself about what it is that you are
so this introduces this weird
bifurcation the truth about what you are
and the lie both both are in the same
consciousness and so he talks about this
is an unstable attitude the person who's
in bad faith vacillates between complete
cynicism and sometimes being in good
faith this can become a normal way of
life for many people as a matter of fact
and it can become the default I think in
in many cultures and it's a way of
avoiding responsibility by treating
oneself as a conscious free being as an
object as an in itself so he has this
example that I think you're all familiar
with but I'll bring it up anyway
of the waiter who is playing at being a
waiter that is he his gestures are a
little bit too histrionic for it for the
situation and you can tell that he's
trying to make himself be a waiter
rather than be a free human being be a
kind of object be a social role be
something that can be determined another
key thing that start talks about is
choosing for oneself involves choosing
not just for oneself but also for
Humanity this is this goes all the way
back to you know your your mother or
aunt or whoever you know reprimanded you
when you did something wrong saying what
if everybody did that Sartre says that
this is part of the structure of freedom
when we act as free human beings were
not just determining what our own
essence is because we end up within
asin's but what the essence of human
being is so if I act like a complete
bastard I'm saying this is the best
human beings can be complete bastards
that's that's why it's okay for me to
act like this or if I did anguish about
it you know and flagellate myself I can
add that to the list as well notice that
other human beings don't have to
our determination of what humanity is
they are also free as well the other
thing that I want to talk about is being
what one does so Sartre is going to tell
us in a very merciless way that we can't
make any appeals to what a person could
have been in the face of what they
really are so all the people who say
that they would have been a great lover
if they'd only found the right person
their soulmate or they would have you
know if they were in 1960s South would
have been a civil rights Crusader even
though all they do is tweet about it
today or you know would have measured up
if the right opportunities have come
along for them to go to the right school
or whatever we want to say Sartre says
all of that is nonsense you are what
you've made of yourself in the freedom
that you have given your situations if
you're not a great artist at this point
that's you know in part because of it
could be because you didn't have the
talent for it but it's also because you
didn't produce any great art and we can
you know we can talk about loving a
person we can talk about jobs we can
talk about all sorts of things in in
this light a few other issues that I
wanted to bring up that we'll talk about
in the longest seminars is you know
which thinkers start is drawing upon and
reinterpreting I mentioned Hegel and
Heidegger very briefly I do want to talk
a bit more about how freedom fits into
this systematic metaphysics developed in
Being and Nothingness I've introduced
you to a few key ideas from that one of
these is the cuttin that I didn't talk
about but but Sartre talks about a lot
is the Cartesian coach Ito why does he
insist upon this so strongly another key
issue is how does my own freedom relate
to the freedom of other people and then
we want to look at what criticisms can
legitimately be made about sart's views
on freedom and I'm thinking that we'll
look at Simone de Beauvoir in particular
and Gabrielle Marcel as two great
interlocutors one his lover one
his rival and enemy so now we've got
some good time for Question and Answer
let me take a look to see what we I
don't messages aren't aren't questions
but so you can use your mic if you want
to you can unmute and ask me or if you
want to ask me in the chat window while
people are viewing that I'm going to
skip ahead a little bit and mention a
few useful resources there is actually a
SART playlist in my youtube channel
with some videos and I'm going to be
adding more videos in the coming months
both on Being and Nothingness and some
of the key ideas in there and also some
of the key ideas and existentialism is a
humanism I may do some stuff from from
some of our our plays and then we have
the deeper dive online seminars coming
up all right so let me switch back to
we've got two questions here one of
which I'll be able to answer and one of
which I don't think I'll be able to
answer here so Scott says Sartre thinks
their lives are totally determined by
personal choice he rejects genetics and
rejects upbringing no he doesn't reject
those he rejects those as totally
determinative of us so you know it's
interesting there's a little bit of a
digression here when when I talk with
people who are engaged in these nurture
versus nature
you know debates I'm always pointing out
to them that it's not as it's not as
simple as either nurture or nature or a
combination of both because we as human
beings have some degree of freedom that
introduces a kind of instability into
the entire schema so so yes genetics do
determine a lot you know being born a
man in the 1970s and being raised a
certain way which is partly genetics and
part
a in a sort of environment or you know
what we call psychological factors
obviously made me a good portion of what
I am right I think some things could be
quite different if I had been born a
woman or had been born in a different
place or a different time so you know
but what I make of that is is up to me
so he's not totally rejecting you know
the effect of genetics but insofar as we
we blame things just on genetics we're
treating ourselves purely as objects
that are determined in the same way that
you know an amoeba would be or an animal
would be we're not recognizing that we
have some some role in it that we can we
can be otherwise
same thing with upbringing you know I
can I can you know I can trace back
parts of how I'm kind of you know
screwed up in my own view to things that
happened when I was a kid you know
whether in the educational system or in
my family but the notion that I can
explain what I have become or or you
know the choices that I make and the
present on that basis art would say is
actually bad faith so there's a complex
interplay there but a great question
say Rainn Williams asked if possible
could you briefly contrast loses notion
of difference again starts idea of
freedom I have not been reading to lose
for for quite some time so I don't feel
competent at this point to try to try to
parse that out because I'm sure I would
just miss remember and mangle things up
in ways that would you know not do
justice to to lose unfortunate and I
hear it here's another digression
unfortunately it's sort of like the
Sherlock Holmes dilemma and in his
resolution of things I'm not sure if you
guys are familiar with this I think it's
in one of the very early books or
stories where Watson is criticizing
homes because Holmes
you know can memorize all of these
different types of tobacco and the ash
that they produce and yet II can't
remember certain basic things you know
English society and and home says well
that's because you know from where I sit
I don't need so much for free to devote
to that I make a choice about what I'm
going to I'm going what I'm going to
allow in there and so I exclude other
things I don't actually do anything so
complicated myself it's more a factor of
how much time I have I think the last
time that I was reading to lose in a
serious way was was several years ago
Scott has a further follow up so what
does he mean when he says he rejects
biological determinism simply that that
that were not determined by our biology
that doesn't mean that we wouldn't have
conditions placed on us by our biology
you know being a for me you know 47 now
year old man I'm very conscious of the
physical limitations of my body in terms
of what I can eat and what I what I
should avoid and how much I can drink
without feeling ill effect for the next
day or things like that
that's all biological right you know you
starts not denying that we we have a
brain and that we can you know look at
brain states or anything like that he's
simply saying that that does not
determine what we are and so there you
know it's a it's one thing to note that
biology creates the situation that we
find ourselves in it's another to say
that you know in an inexorable way
everything unfolds from that biology the
way that you see some people trying to
claim all right what other questions or
comments
do people have
oh okay so Scott has a follow-up here so
this is actually a really good
elucidation he says we all have
different paths to who we are some have
to work harder or differently yeah I
think Sartre is perfectly willing to say
that you know depending on what we're
trying to do some of us do have to work
harder at it so I'm going to I'm going
to have a sort of silly example here but
if you've ever seen any pictures of
Sartre he's got what we call a walleye
you know he's different actions and time
and even if his eyeballs were both
pointed in the same direction he would
not have been the best looking guy in
most rooms
now Sartre was also quite a womanizer so
presumably he had a real interest you
know despite having Simone de Beauvoir
as his longtime partner and companion he
had a real interest in having a very
active sexual life and romantic life
Sartre undoubtedly had to work quite a
bit harder at that than would have say
Albert Camus it was a pretty
good-looking guy and so you know there's
there's lots of different things going
on here now when it comes to working
harder the key thing to think about
though is who sets the criteria for you
know where you're supposed to be going
and Sartre thinks that and we can get
all sorts of answers coming to us from
our upbringing for example or from the
culture that we inhabit but ultimately
it's up to us what we decide we want to
do with those which Boyce's we're going
to give priority to and listen to and
which which we won't all right so say
Ron Williams has two questions about
about Marxism between Lukesh and starts
with respect to their view
marxism who do you think in the end had
a more comprehensive philosophy I guess
it depends on what we mean by
comprehensive if we're asking like who
more thoroughly integrated Marxism I
guess it would probably be lukacs again
somebody who I have not been reading for
for several years if we're talking about
comprehensive in the sense of trying to
produce it like a whole system of fun I
think Sartre
I mean he's not doing so very much in
Being and Nothingness he has some some
interesting discussions for example of
you know where the the workers are
[Music]
realizing they're being exploited so
clearly he's thinking in terms of
Marxist but he's also criticizing the
Marxist at various points um but there
was a lot of that sort of kernel Marxist
who used Marxism more effectively in
their thought I don't know that the it
depends on what we're talking about is
as effective
I mean Sark is is there's you know we
can talk about and sort of earlier
Sartre and then a later start like when
we talk about the critique of
dialectical materialism you know I'm not
sure what we mean by effectiveness in
this case so but again it has attempt to
weigh in on Lukesh because you know not
somebody who I'm I'm actively working
with very much I you know the sideline I
would say that the majority of my time
these days the people who I'm you know
deeply reading and rereading are Plato
Aristotle the Stoics Plutarch and some
Thomas Aquinas Hobbes Descartes
Hegel Heidegger Sartre
Nietzsche those I mean and that's you
know probably going to change as I have
to develop other video series or stuff
like that but those are the people that
I'm like hitting over and over again so
that that's enough to keep you pretty
busy unfortunately I wish I had a lot
more time to to read everybody because
I've got all great mesh columns to play
definitely is good too
what other questions that people have we
can some say I went over about five
minutes in the presentation will take
another five minutes or so of fashion's
ah so Scott if so start reject God
altogether yeah he served as an atheist
and interestingly he does note he's
talking about the other way of going
about it
he's talking about that you know
somebody who's a convert to Christianity
who converted from being sort of a
militant atheist before is in a very
very different position than somebody
who just you know sort of takes up
Christianity without that all that
background who were somebody who was
raised in Christianity and never left it
and and Sartre is you know he's you
could say he's kind of a principled
atheist he's definitely rejecting there
being any sort of transcendence God who
could determine anything he provides
some good discussions of that in Being
and Nothingness and you know Gabrielle
Marcel was one of his main criticisms
against Sartre is that he he essentially
just assumes an atheistic posture as
being the correct one and then proceeds
on that basis on that some of the some
of what you find in sort
it's philosophy that gives it a bit of
its austerity and harshness stems from
that I think it's you know it's quite
possible to reject some of the notions
of God that Sartre is rejecting like God
being the you know the deus big clock
maker or God being just you know the one
who creates everything or you know God
being sort of humanity writ large
without rejecting every other notion of
God that's another point that people
like Marcel will make but yeah Sartre
was Sartre was definitely a committed
atheist I mean he thought that if God
existed that would inevitably impinge
upon human freedom and so you know he
was this big advocate of freedom oh so
here's an ant really interesting
question by say Ron Williams do you
think Nietzsche would be generally
receptive to start early philosophy and
Being and Nothingness
I don't and I think that in part that
would be because of I think nature would
read Sartre as in many respects a new
kind of idealist you know Sartre have
such a strong emphasis on consciousness
on what he's calling the the cart that
cocoa Jeeto which is going beyond that
of the cart but but it's still you know
very much within the sphere of
consciousness and Sartre is also
attempting to provide a kind of unified
theory of you know being you know the
being in itself and our our relation to
it so yeah I think nature would probably
have a lot to criticize
all right any other last questions
before I wrap this up
start Scott sets our tasks Scott asked
any note on starts view on Aristotle
I mean Sartre doesn't engage with
Aristotle very much he I'll say two
things that'll be a good wrap-up point
so start has a very interesting
discussion of emotions which could
compliment Aristotle's discussion of the
emotions but as far as I know nobody's
ever made them do so and cert would
largely be announcing Aristotle through
the people who were endorsing him at the
time who were mainly you know what we
now call neo scholastics it is these you
know largely Catholic thinkers who were
quite often you know treating Aristotle
in a rather schematic way and you know
start would you know Aristotle thinks
there are essences right so Sartre is
rejecting that for for human beings I
mean it would be a very interesting
project again one that unfortunately the
time is not available to to really work
on how to sort of put those two together
into a useful dialogue so all right I'm
seeing a lot of thank yous come in
you're very welcome
great questions and I hope to see some
of you at the the online the online
seminars and look for some of these
these other webinars in the future so
have a great day